all right what's going on people I am
caffeinated and ready to roll so we were
going to do this at 7:00 p.m. Pacific
tonight but then some scheduling things
happen I literally just landed from
Philadelphia this morning Boston two
days ago Toronto the day before that
just landed in LA we're taping two shows
today I'm not gonna reveal everything
right now one of the guests is a little
late so we thought we'd do this now
maxing out the time here I have so many
things that I want to share with you
guys there is so much good stuff
happening right now
this tour with Jordan Peterson's been
amazing my return to stand-up there's so
many signs and signals that the things
that we're talking about here are really
taking root I think that this
intellectual dark web article from Barry
Weiss in the New York Times two weeks
ago really really leveled this thing up
and and it's just reached all across
everything and it wouldn't even be just
that it's the good part of the article
that reached across everything it's that
the amount of hysteria and angry people
and misrepresentations of all of our
views and all that the amount of
articles being written about it and
think pieces and all this nonsense it's
like man we must be doing something
right over here that all these people
are just making up this nonsense and to
be on tour with Jordan Peterson we're
literally literally every day there is
another ridiculous hit piece written
about him often I've met the author of
the piece the New York Times when they
came out this week about his enforced
monogamy idea I was in the greenroom on
the first night of the tour I believe in
Toronto two weeks ago with with the girl
who wrote the piece and it's just like
man journalism is freaking dying and
dead and by the way with that in mind
we're getting some new allies in this
space Elan musk has been on a freaking
tear about mainstream media so I think
there's a lot of interesting things
happen the Dali Lama tweeted something
about individualism and coming together
as people I think there's so much cool
stuff happening right now I'm totally
enthused
I'm meeting literally thousands of you
guys you know at these events most of
the theaters that we're doing are about
three to five thousand people I think
the biggest one we did was the Apollo in
London which was 5,000 people I mean
think about that 5,000 people coming to
here a psychologist talk about ideas you
know it's just awesome so I usually go
up there I do about 10 to 15 minutes to
stand up I get the crowd growing we're
talking about lobsters and cleaning your
room and all this crazy stuff and I just
get everybody having a good time and and
the beauty is you can feel it that for
you watching this right now for most
people watching this stuff it's like
you're watching this most likely on your
on your phone or you're on a computer
it's a pretty singular experience right
maybe you're with somebody but usually
you're not watching it a whole group of
people although I have heard that now
some students are watching the show and
there's some groups there's a group in
India that I think gets together on
Sunday nights and watches my show it's
amazing but generally speaking you're
watching this as a solo experience and
you're kind of just we're doing this
right but to be in a room with 5,000
people who agree disagree black white
gay straight all of that stuff all of
that diversity but are just coming
together to hear about ideas and then
hear Jordan talk about why racism is not
good why the alt-right is bad why
cultural Marxism and progressivism are
all so bad and just everybody getting on
board talking about personal
responsibility it's just it really I
feel like my life even from two weeks
ago my life has changed cuz you can't be
around that kind of force for that long
and and not feel something it just it
feels real and honest and and good and I
think we're we're challenging each other
Jordan has made it very clear that
nothing is off-limits during the Q&A so
usually I take some questions from the
crowd that they there there's an app
that they send questions in on but then
I mix it up with some of my own stuff
he's challenged me a little bit on some
things it's been it's been a total
learning experience and very cool all
right so here's what we're gonna do here
so on top of the Jordan Peterson tour
which I'm heading back out on our next
stop is in Houston and the Dallas and
then Austin we're doing a little Texas
thing starting in a couple days but I am
here for a couple days we're booking
some stand-up stuff for me around some
of the tour's stuff so I've got three
shows that I want to tell you guys about
and for anyone that buys a ticket
during this if you're watching this
right now and you're one of the
first we're gonna do this for 20 people
at each one of these venues
we've got DC coming up we've got Tempe
Arizona and we've got Seattle am i right
yes okay if you are watching this and
you're one of the first 20 people to buy
a ticket to the show and the links are
right down below while you're watching
this we're gonna let you in to the to
the meet and greet I do a meet and greet
afterwards shake hands say hi take
pictures all that good stuff we'll let
you get in that for free there's a
premium charge for that but we'll do it
for free so the links to the show are
right down below it's Tempe Arizona of
Tempe improv that is on June Tempe is
June 3rd that's that's basically next
week we got the DC improv on June 7th
and the Seattle we're gonna be at the
parlor live in Seattle that's on June
20th so what you do is if you buy a
ticket screenshot it send it to contact
at Reuben report.com we're gonna get you
in on the meet and greet after contact
at Reuben report com just send your your
screenshot that you bought some tickets
and we'll get you in we'll say hi we'll
do all that good stuff maybe I'll go out
and hang out and have drinks after I
don't know we'll see what what's going
on okay you know what I was supposed to
say ten people per but I said twenty I'm
a man of my word all right guys it's 20
per 20 per show so there's 60 60 slots
if you happen to be near DC or Seattle
or Tempe Arizona which is right by
Phoenix where I'll be with your in a
couple days so anyway so I'm just I'm
just as you can tell I'm just psyched
about what's going on here these shows
we were in we were in London last week
5,000 people at the Apollo Theater it
was just incredible I got out so usually
the way these theater is working on
these are huge awesome old school you
know Phantom of the Opera Theater is
just beautiful beautiful buildings most
of them and they usually have like an
artist's entrance or something but for
the the one in London I didn't know
where the artists entrance was so my
uber just dropped me off right in front
there were out there 2,000 people
outside I got stormed I mean it was
crazy like the amount of people that are
so excited about this stuff and and
everyone talking about their political
awakening and the same [ __ ] that you
were thinking about that I talked about
here about what it's like to evolve
politically and realize that you were
wrong about some things in wanna
more and everyone has like an amazing
life story to tell me and people always
they want to give us stuff everyone
wants to give Jordan personal written
notes or some people have done some
incredible artwork and stuff like that
like it's just been it's been so cool
but as I said before it's that it's that
everyone's coming together people are
looking around and going whoa
you're a Jordan Peterson fan you know
you know Dave Rubin like it's just like
it's like real it really feels like real
real real and cool all right let's see
so I'm gonna take a couple questions by
the way
so we're gonna do the super chat thing
if you're watching right now on the
YouTube we're doing super chat it's real
quick on YouTube I don't know if you saw
this I guess they announced this
yesterday I tweeted about it today but
they're gonna be there experimenting
with changing the feed because we really
want more of that sort of thing where
they're going to they're gonna sort of
rejigger your feed to figure out what
you might want to watch instead of
showing you stuff in chronological order
now call me a conspiracy theorist but if
they don't really like the stuff that
the content creator is putting out there
it seems that they might just hurt you
and everyone else's feed everyone wants
just a chronological feed right you
subscribe to things because you know you
like them and if you don't want if they
put up a clip that you don't like if I
put up an interview that you don't like
you don't watch it but we don't need
youtube or any more of these algorithms
to do more hiding things from us or
promoting other things and we know that
there's just so many ways that that can
be manipulated but they're experimenting
that right now and by the way I'm not
asking the government to come in and fix
the problem I'm using my voice my free
speech I see this on Twitter all the
time people will say see Ruben you're
you don't want any regulation you don't
want the government to come in and fix
anything well now look what happened
with YouTube and the NFL and bah-bah-bah
and no I don't want the government to
come in and fix these things I don't
think the government can fix YouTube I
don't think the government make it fix
the NFL or anything else the government
can't do that much especially the
federal government because it certainly
can't do it well or efficiently so what
you can do and what is your right and
duty as an American is to use your voice
to express pleasure or displeasure or
whatever it else with any company so
when I tweet about YouTube people's out
you can see you don't want the
government of also you can't whine about
it no that's the whole point
you should complain so that hopefully
someone up there some of the higher-ups
go whoa you know there's a bunch of
creators out there and it's not just me
by the way that are complaining and
these guys seem to have some influence
and they're using our platform maybe we
should think about what our
decision-making is here that's what you
do in a free society I can't nobody's
forcing me to be on YouTube right and
they don't have to let me be on YouTube
but as long as they're letting me be on
YouTube I can use my voice to affect the
platform and that's exactly what you
guys can do and by the way one day I
assume and I have a reason to believe
that there's plenty of competition
coming down the pike don't want to say
too much you know what I mean but I just
think there's there's opportunity and
competition and capitalism that's the
answer to all of these problems alright
so here we go
reminder though you guys should click
that Bell on the subscription thing if
you click the bell and I think it'll
give you a couple options like how much
you want to be notified that way you'll
hopefully if they're not manipulating
this thing too much you'll see the
videos and all that bad that being said
our subscriber growth has exploded in
the last month every now and again
suddenly we see these odd anomalies and
then I contact them and they say oh
nothing's going on but people keep
telling me they're being unsubscribed
bla bla bla it's but a bunch of insider
stuff ok reminder one more time and then
I'm gonna dive into some questions any
of you guys that are watching this
either live or or after depending on how
many people jump in we have 20 slots at
each of the three shows in Seattle and
Tempe and in DC and if you screenshot
your tickets that you purchase while you
are watching this we will let you into
the meet and greet after absolutely free
they charge extra for that but we'll do
it for free and I'll say Heidi and all
that good stuff the links to the shows
are down below I've only done one
hour-long show so far it was the Irvine
improv couple weeks ago it was it was
awesome I give you my word but the
manager came up to me after she said
that was the first sold-out standing
ovation she had seen in 18 years of
working there I'm not making this up by
the way I'm a it's a little unclear
right now perhaps there will be a guest
or two from the intellectual dark web
that will join me on these on these
shows but I do about you know an hour
then I do some live Q&A fiddle around if
you guys or all kinds of fun stuff it's
great to just get back to my old life of
doing that it's it's completely
different than what
guys know of me sort of doing the
interview thing I'm also working on the
book again because I've been signing
because people come up to me after the
shows they want me to sign something and
they all have Jordans book so I've been
signing Jordans book which seems unjust
so I finally just because I've been so
busy it's been put on the back burner a
little bit finally really dove back into
it the last couple days so we're working
on that too a lot of good stuff
happening okay
super chat patreon questions let's do a
little something what's an example of a
view that you've been challenged on well
I think the one that everyone knows the
most is from last week's guest larry
elder although this happened about two
and a half years ago when we were
talking about systemic racism way back
when and that's when i still considered
myself sort of more part of the left or
progressive or whatever you want to call
it i was kind of just waking up to a lot
of that stuff and and larry just beat me
senseless there are many clips of this I
think on YouTube one of the clips
someone just took our clip straight up
which we're fine with it has about a
million views of Larry just beating me
that systemic racism meaning the laws
that are built into the system doesn't
exist it doesn't mean that racism
doesn't exist there are always going to
be racists there are going to be bigots
there are going to be people that don't
like black people and people that don't
like gay people and everything uh people
don't like white people and everything
else but you can't you can't change
everyone in a society and if you want to
change everyone who decided you're
probably a pretty bad person actually
but what you can do is make sure that
all the laws are equal so that everyone
has equal opportunity equality of
opportunity you can't get to that where
we're gonna have equal outcome because
some people are gonna be more talented
some people are gonna work harder some
people are gonna be luckier but you want
equal opportunity for everybody and I
would say that the way that you would
deal with so people always say well
alright well what about some historic
and justices and all that sort of thing
well then I would want education to be
focused on let's get it down to the
state level and let's make it slimmer
and trimmer and use money better and not
not you know poor so much money into
federal programs that don't really work
and having everybody just learn so that
they can pass the test without actually
learning and all that stuff so education
I think is where you can make a lot of
movement if you want to get people to be
more
surely equal but watch but Larry doing
that I think you know I've always said
it's it was sort of the best moment and
worst moment of my career at the same
time it was the worst moment because I
went into a conversation not ready not
armed so when I said this thing about
systemic racism and he turned it back on
me I was kind of like a deer in
headlights
so it was my worst moment for that but
it was my best moment because we let it
be uh you know I've told this many times
Tremayne you guys know this but we were
at aura TV at the time we go into the
control room right after the show and
there was a we had a bigger staff at the
time and then one of the producers said
to me you know you guys got to cut that
from the show and I said no we got to
leave that that is a human moment that
is a real moment I don't mind being
wrong I don't mind being humbled and I
don't mind being shown up actually but
it's done the right way you know what I
mean I don't want to be belittled or
attacked or something but he wasn't
attacking me he was attacking my ideas
and my ideas were shaky so I think it
was a good lesson for me and I and I've
heard from literally hundreds if not
thousands of you guys that it was a good
lesson for you guys as well where can
you get this hoodie this is the Reuben
report this is the official Reuben
report hoodie you can get the hoodie at
Reuben report.com slash shop I'm correct
it's shop not store I believe it is
Reuben report.com slash shop we got we
got hoodies we got t-shirts we got
cut-offs store it's store Reuben report
calm slash store I've been I've been
freaking busy people I'm bouncing around
the world here I have a busy Reuben
report calm slash store and we got all
kinds of stuff over there and there's
there's some cool stuff we got classical
liberal t-shirts libertarian ish and a
whole bunch of other stuff and it's a
great way of supporting us a little bit
and and you know spread and worried
about what you're doing okay quick
reminder the three shows are Tempe
improv June 3rd
DC Improv June 7th and Seattle at parlor
live on June 20th any of you watching
this first twenty at any of those things
if you buy a ticket to any of those
shows the links right down below we will
get you into the meet-and-greet for free
if you email us the ticket stub so we
see you that you actually bought the
ticket at contact at Reuben report.com
how's Emma doing Emma dog
many of you guys know Emma she gets in
some of my behind the scenes videos
every now and again have Emma will be 14
what's today is today the 22nd she is
today the 22nd guys she will be 14 on
June 22nd she's a rescue from New
Orleans from Hurricane Katrina she's
just the greatest dog in the world and
and still spry for what 14 what are you
like a 95 year old dog or something yeah
she's she's great thanks for asking
someone on Facebook are you high no I'm
not I'm I have been drinking a lot of
coffee because it's hard to be on all
these flights and you know last week
when I came back from London we had to
tape a couple shows like that morning
and I was way jet-lagged I didn't sleep
on a 10-hour flight for some reason so
my caffeine levels all right are you
noticing a higher energy is that what's
going on here no I am NOT high and and
even if I was high
I mean I've mentioned this before I
don't smoke weed that often maybe once
or twice a week and I like indica which
is that's the one that takes you down I
don't need to be high to be more in my
head you know I mean I don't need any of
these doors open more I would close a
couple of them if it's possible so I I
do like a hit of indica 11 o'clock at
night and I watch The Simpsons or
Seinfeld and go to sleep so no I'm not
high promise you okay let's see from
Facebook any chance of continuing the
founding fathers slash historic figures
series yeah so first off I was so
thrilled that so many of you like that
as much as I did where we did presidents
week five different presidents with five
different scholars in five days and
learn liberty helped us produce that I
just loved every second of it I mean you
guys know I just love that actually
speaking about it I was in Philadelphia
esterday I went to the Liberty Bell went
to Constitution Center I just love all
of that history I love those documents
we just got you know we'll post it on on
Twitter right after it's and we'll post
it on Facebook as well when I was at a
turning point event last month there's a
guy that gives that prints these giant
prints of the Declaration of
Independence in the Constitution
so he sent them to us and we just put
them up in the green room so now we've
got a massive old vintage American flag
and we've got those up there it's all
very cool
but I just love that I love history I
didn't you know I've always loved
history but I think this you guys
learning about this stuff I'm learning
right with you
so I love that week I love being in
Philadelphia I love when I go to DC and
I you know go to all the monuments and
all that stuff so yes we're trying to
figure out something else we can do with
learn Liberty in that vein but for sure
we'll do more of those and also I just
to me it's like people are too upset and
obsessed more than upset they're too
obsessed with the day-to-day
machinations of politics what a leak
happened at the White House and this
happened and that happened and it's like
this isn't news you know last night so I
saw an old buddy of mine from college
Mike if you're watching this I'm giving
me a live shoutout my friend Mike by the
way great guy he once beat we were
sophomores in college he beat Super
Mario Brothers I think in nine minutes
and 47 seconds if you max warp to level
four max warp to eight and you plow
right through 83 which i think is the
top one yeah and then you got to figure
out the dungeon on 84 he beat it in nine
minutes and forty some odd seconds
anyway great guy
so I I saw him last night and he I went
out with him and some other people and
we were sitting at the hotel bar and
they had a huge television screen like
not even it was like a huge wall of TVs
basically for for huge TVs on a big wall
with many screens and CNN was on one and
MSNBC was on the other or whatever like
a ticker was on another one and I think
the sports thing was on the other and I
was facing them so they were looking at
me and I buy of the TV kind of over over
their shoulders and I was just I never
watched that crap anymore and it just
seemed so dumb at one point I got up I
was like I can't sit here anymore
because I keep being distracted by this
dribble another headline that trumped
this and it's just nothing so we
actually switched seats then they were
bothered by it and then we actually just
shifted around altogether okay here we
go let's see how long are you planning
on doing the Reuben report that's a good
question I mean you know it's funny I
say this too to Amira and to Alexis and
to David and and to Talia all the time
it's like I were just the beginning
again it's crazy but like everything
that we've worked for everything that
we've talked
about the conversations we're having it
all feels more relevant right this very
second than it's ever felt so I have no
plans of doing anything else I've been
meeting with a whole slew of people
about all kinds of other different
projects that I can be involved with new
on the side I mean I'm people are
reaching out to me with all kinds of
interesting offers I can't get into all
of them right now or I really can't get
into any of them because you don't talk
about [ __ ] until the pain is dry but I
love doing this I really love doing this
and I feel I just feel more validated
than ever
while doing it and it's great and I hope
that I'll keep getting better and all
that good stuff okay here we go what are
we doing here today we're talking about
the Petersons tour which has just been
just been spectacular and I'm so I any
of you that are watching right now I
hope I've met some of you out there just
been great just saying hi to people and
people from every walk of life and every
age and sexuality in color and all of
that stuff and high school people and
people in this in their senior years and
everything in between it's been so cool
but yes I'm busting out the stand up
it's coming back people our plus a my
stand-up plus perhaps some intellectual
darkweb guests June third Tempe improv
links right down below
June 7th at the DC Improv link right
down below Seattle parlor live June 20th
link right down below the first 20 of
you at each one of those venues who buys
a ticket while you're watching this even
if it's late even you're not watching
live if 20 of you have not done it yet
you can still get in on this will will
upgrade you to the meet-and-greet after
where I come and hang out with you guys
and take pictures and all that good
stuff so you just got to buy the ticket
at the link down below screenshot it
contact at Reuben report com just send
it to us and we'll take good care yeah
okay so we've got we got VIP spots
available for you guys all right let's
see what's going on here hey Dave as a
classical liberal what do you think
about the NFL requiring players to stand
for the national anthem is this a free
speech issue or an employer rights issue
okay I got into this today with David
Frum on Twitter and by the way I invited
him to come back on the show he's in LA
next week but I'm on tour so I think
we're gonna do it in October that's when
he said he'll be back on but we're a
little bit of a
he compared this to the James d'amour
situation at Google and it's nothing
like the James d'amour situation James
d'amour was invited to go to these
diversity training things and then told
afterwards to share his thoughts which
he then did with Google then they
punished him for sharing his thoughts
they fired him for his political beliefs
and for doing exactly what they told him
to do and by the way it was just two or
three months after he had just gotten a
promotion this is not that case no one
has been fired Kaepernick was not hired
he was a free agent he wasn't hired by
any team but he wasn't fired and you
have to understand that these things are
all businesses so let's let me just try
to do this as cleanly and clearly as
possible and as Jordan says every night
you have to be very precise with your
language I am a free speech absolutist
you can say whatever you want within the
constructs of the few things that under
the law you are not allowed to do so you
cannot make a direct threat I'm going to
kill you I'm going to kill all of those
people right I'm gonna blow up that you
can't do that you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater there's public safety
issues and then we have extremely
extremely specific very hard to prove
libel laws okay
which I believe in actually because you
can't especially nowadays with the
amount of just evil noxious toxic
journalism out there and social media
and all that if you you have to have
some protection around that by the way
these laws are virtually never used and
I believe they should exist but with
those exceptions you can say whatever
you want you're allowed to be mean
you're allowed to say bad things you're
allowed to upset people et cetera et
cetera you're allowed to say things
about protected groups you can't say
we're gonna kill them but you're allowed
to say mean things I would prefer you
didn't
I would prefer everyone be real nice to
each other right and that's what
conversation is all about that's my
feeling on free speech okay so that's
one thing now if if you watch the video
that I did and I tweeted it out today so
you can find it on the NFL protests from
seven months ago I stand by everything
that I said you know everyone was
treating this thing like there was this
massive assault on free speech and
that the government was stopping people
from speaking in all this stuff so let's
let's try to do it cleanly here the
players can do what they want right the
players can either kneel or not this is
I'm getting up to the point of yesterday
right or I guess it happened today with
the the new regulations that they're
gonna have so we're just going back
seven months at that point the players
could do what everyone you could kneel
or not kneel you can express yourself
however you want the team then can do
whatever it wants it can either find you
or not fine you or you know put out a
statement saying they agree with you or
not
the owners can do whatever they want
with their business the league can do
whatever it wants the president although
I would preferred that Trump not gotten
involved in this in the first place he
can say whatever he wants now he called
the players I think he called the
players sons of [ __ ] or something
that's freakin ridiculous and awful and
he shouldn't do that but he is entitled
to his free speech as well even even
when at that level it's it's a pretty
gross thing that he said but everyone's
free speech in this instance was expose
respected everyone was allowed to do
whatever they want now that doesn't mean
you aren't gonna suffer repercussions so
let's say at the end of the day an owner
looks and they go you know we've got
these players kneeling now we see our
audience is turning against us because
our audience doesn't want that
we see our TV ratings dropping we see
attendance dropping we see merchandise
not selling as well well I'm in a
business I'm a business owner I own a
team they own a team for a reason you're
allowed to then not hire people you're
allowed to fire people I mean this again
this has nothing to do with the
government so this was actually even
though it all felt weird it was
government working now if Trump or the
government or any state official or
whatever it is would have used coercion
of the government to say you have to
stand of course people of course I would
be absolutely against that but they did
not do that now what happened yesterday
or it was earlier today I'm I've been
traveling so much I'm a little unclear
is that it sounds like what they're
gonna do is if you don't want to come
if you're a player and you don't want to
come out for the national anthem they're
just gonna ask you to stay in the locker
room that's a the league making its
decision and the players now can choose
whether to abide by that or not and if
they don't abide by it and they go out
there and they kneel and the league has
said you cannot do that well then
they're gonna suffer the repercussions
they are a hundred percent as far as I
could tell from everything I read today
you could spend the other six days of
the week and and 21 some odd hours - the
three hours that you're on the field
playing football you can be protesting
you can be tweeting you can do whatever
you want but the league has a right to
say what it's standards are just as
YouTube by the way has a right to do
whatever it wants again I mean I think I
started this off by saying that these
companies can do whatever they want the
idea that the government can come in and
either fix them or tell them what to do
is just something that I just simply
don't believe in and I've never heard a
compelling argument for it and by the
way I know that I disagree with this on
some people that I absolutely respect so
my basic feeling so your question was
how would a classical liberal feel about
this I mean a classical liberal
basically you believe in lays a fair
economics you want a very light if at
all touch of the government on these
decisions so as long as no one's rights
were infringed on no one no one was
stopped from speaking in other words if
you're if look I have a business here
right let's say tomorrow
Emira came in here and said you know for
the first half hour that I'm working
every day I'm gonna protest something
and I'm gonna stand here with a picket
fence and I'm gonna you know the picket
sign and blah blah blah
well I might be like you know what you
have a right to do that you have a right
to express your free speech of course
but you can't do it on my dime does
anyone think that me as a small business
man would have to hire someone that
wasn't working the entire the entire
time that I was there doing the
expectations which I've set forth I
don't think so
so again this is where freedom is messy
it doesn't all feel good I don't want
people to have to be left in the locker
room and all of all the underlying
reasons that they're doing this protest
in the first place but everyone in this
case is allowed to make their choice the
owners the league the players
the fans everyone is expressing
themselves accordingly and if you're not
happy what the league did then don't
watch and if you are happy then do watch
and buy stuff so you gotta let freedom
ring you gotta let it ring that's what I
think about that okay
are you staying on the diet while on the
tour I basically am it's been obviously
a little bit tough and I did have a
cheesesteak while I was in Philly I
wasn't gonna go to Philly and not have a
cheesesteak but yeah I've been doing it
and so since we started this thing which
was a little bit I think was right into
the first week of January of this year
I'm down about 20 pounds I'm gonna try
to go for about five more I know I don't
really meet it but it's like once you
start like feeling real good and you you
look in the mirror and you see those
differences and I just feel good in
general I think really getting get a
sugar out so I'm doing this sort of slow
carb paleo thing very very low carb but
mostly just meat and fish and and
vegetables really got sugar out more
than anything else and I feel good I
feel clean I feel clear I feel lighter
for sure so I'm gonna just keep trying
to do it and then I guess at some point
when I get to some magic number then I
just got to figure out how to how to
kind of balance it out all right we got
about 20 20 minutes here what are we
doing here people I got three stand-up
events coming and I want you to come
backstage for no extra charge okay that
was my best became like 1980s salesman
right there Tempe improv June third DC
Improv June 7th Seattle at the parlor
live if you buy a ticket right now and
you're one of the first 20 people at any
of those events at any of those specific
locations screenshot it right now
screenshot that you bought the tickets
send it to contact at Rubin report calm
and we're gonna let you in the meet and
greet for free I'll say Heidi I'll give
you a high five we'll take a selfie all
that good stuff and we're doing that for
twenty people per event okay here we go
dig in the art in the background so we
got a lot of compliments on the art so
there's this blue one here right there
that's Kalin Rose Janet who's done a
bunch of artwork in my house and she did
the paint the painting that's on the
other side of the guest a lot of people
see that say that they see Kurt Cobain
in there you see I can kind of see it
like there's an eye and there's an eye
there's the nose and a mouth over there
yeah so that's that
I always forget who did who did this
whoops
I always forget who did the that one
right there Emira knows we'll post it in
the comments
yeah it's I like having a good art we
may do some refreshing around here and
change a few things as time goes by but
yeah there you go
let's see can you tell us who the bad
actors are specifically I'm not sure
what you're referring to I do talk about
bad actors often but I don't know what
you're specifically talking about I in
general when I talk about bad actors I'm
talking about people that are just
misquoting people intentionally people
who are doing clickbait titles whether
it's on YouTube or on you know just
print whatever it is people who are just
lying about what other people are saying
people more than anything else people
who were talking about people all the
time I mean think about what I've done
here for the last hour I've talked about
ideas I don't care about talking about
specific people even Trump that much I
would much rather talk about the
underlying ideas the the fact that there
are so many journalists who wake up in
the morning and they're like today I'm
gonna get Ruben or I'm gonna get Sam
era's or I'm gonna get Jordan Peterson
or anybody and it's like if you think
that we're the biggest problem out there
you're you're a little misguided in what
you're doing so I don't like talking
about people and if your goal every day
is to talk about people and attack
people and and smear and lie and slander
and all that stuff I just don't think
you're a good actor in this space and
what I when I say this space I mean just
the in the space of people talking about
ideas I'm not perfect I'm not always
right but if you are acting in good
faith then I'm then I'm happy to talk to
you okay let's see what else is going on
here
is Mike Pence a cyborg there's he's a
little robotic there's no doubt that the
guy's a little stiff so I think it's I'd
say there he could be 10% robot is
Hillary Clinton a lizard possibly both
cannot be true well anything's possible
good question good question okay let's
see alright what else do I want to tell
you I'm gonna let a couple a couple
other questions load in here on patreon
in super chat you know bouncing around
this thing and going to all these cities
what also has been nice about it just in
the last couple weeks beyond beyond you
in London which was great oh I spoke at
Oxford Union which hopefully the video
will be up on their channel in a day or
two it was just wonderful
so Oxford Union it's in it's in Oxford
which is about an hour away from London
and I didn't realize this but it's a
small collection of colleges some of the
colleges are very small I think
someone's only one of the colleges is
like 14 people and then some Akaya
some have hundreds of cetera and it's in
this really great quaint old town that
you kind of feel like you're in Harry
Potter and it really is one of the last
bastions of free speech at the academic
level and it was just wonderful so what
we did was they were probably about it
was standing room only I don't know
maybe about 200 students there the
president of Oxford Union a lovely young
lady she asked me questions I didn't
know anything in advance they they let
you do it however you want so she said
you know I could give an opening
statement and then we could do a QA and
then we'll take questions from the crowd
she could ask me questions interviewing
me however you want to do it I said you
know what I'm so used to being on this
side of the interview let me just sit
down I don't need to make an opening
statement just start asking me whatever
you think she asked some pretty
challenging questions right from beat
one and the audience asked spectacular
questions and challenged me on some
stuff and it was a true joy every second
of it was a joy and then I I had a drink
with with some of the students after and
it was like all of these kids again and
I I hate having to say this but I think
it's important because of all the smear
pieces the diversity of color and
ethnicity and background and religion
and all and and sexuality and all that
it's all there and stop thinking that
people's ideas are based on those things
what a sad way to live you know what a
sad way to live it was just great
super chat mate I love what you're about
thank you mate I love your love so thank
you very much for that yeah so so London
but then we get back to the states and
just in the last couple days as I said
we did Boston we did Philly we did
Toronto we did Denver we did we're doing
Texas bunch of stops in Texas we did oh
man we've been all over the place like
it's actually it's hard for me to even
like categorize exactly where we've been
but what's been nice is that each we did
San Francisco what's nice is that each
is its own thing we did Seattle it's
like you could really get a flavor for
each thing so the shows that I've
enjoyed the most so far san francisco is
spectacular
because I brought up Eric Weinstein as a
surprise so I did about 10 minutes get
the crowds going crazy and then I was
like you know what
here's another member of the IDW I bring
out Eric Weinstein he plays the
harmonica he goes up there plays the
harmonica for about a minute 3,000
people applauding and it was like man I
go backstage with him after and it's
like this guy is so accomplished in
mathematics and and economics and you
know he works with Peter Thiel and it
was like the true joy on this guy's face
that he got to play the harmonica for
3,000 people and that they loved it it
was just so awesome what I found is that
the the cities that leaned a little more
left so a Seattle San Francisco for
example that's where the crowds have
been the hottest because I think because
they're the outliers there they come and
they're like holy cow we're here with
other people kind of would think like us
so it's very exciting but but really all
of the shows have been good they they're
all sort of different Philly last night
it was a little more of a working-class
crowd you could tell but it's great and
and people are coming to get dressed up
people are wearing suits and and and you
know girls are wearing dresses it's just
it really it's just great it's just it's
just been a true joy all right a couple
other things here let's see do you still
open your open yourself to having your
mind changed as the intellectual dark
web gains momentum how do you make sure
you're not becoming dogmatic in your
views I mean all I can do is constantly
be open to ideas and and see where the
best ones fall I don't think there's any
you know that's really the beauty of
this thing you know I saw some of the
hit pieces on this where they tried to
frame us as a mostly white male group
now first up we all just happen to come
together I don't even know what this
thing is exactly I don't know what the
gatekeeping is that's what a lot of the
discussion is about we don't have a card
we don't have a clubhouse
but yes are there a bunch of people but
by the way I would say that that you
know it obviously also includes you know
it's not just that it's white men which
even if it was just white men straight
white men and I'm not even one of them
even if it was that has nothing to do
with the set of ideas so it's really
interesting that the same people who
tell every
what else that they're bigots and
racists and homophobes and all that
they're the ones actually practicing
bigotry in this case but the group is
truly diverse we've got ideas all over
the place and we've got men and women
and gays and straights in the rest of it
so the best I can do is continually be
open to ideas so by the way you know
it's like two weeks ago I had a lipid
libertarian economics professor Don
Boudreaux from George Mason University
ah now he happens to fall into a lot of
the ideas that I've come to really love
I love you know it's it we did a little
bit of what's the difference between a
classical liberal and a libertarian he's
he's into the and cap stuff which
intellectually I just think it's a fun
exercise of if you want to follow
through your logic of where small
government leads I think it's a fun
conversation to have so I really enjoyed
that then what did we do this past
Monday we put up our interview with who
do we have on on Monday man I've been
traveling a lot
Jenny Wilson thank you Jenny Wilson
who's a Democrat running in a deep red
state of Utah and now obviously when it
came to certain issues where we talked
about diversity we came to certain
issues about economics we didn't agree
and we agree I think at one point we
actually said we agreed to disagree and
then we moved on and it's like I loved
having that conversation - I this is
what it's about and I think 80% of us I
really believe this 80% of us are in
that same space and it's the fringes on
both sides that are loud and annoying
my concern is much more obviously with
the with the extremes of the left
because they have so much to do with
media and television and politics and no
one has ever called far left in the
media even though most of the Democratic
establishment at this point is pretty
far left and everyone is smeared as far
right or all right but I'm I will keep
doing it and call me out if you think
I'm becoming dogmatic in my approach
please call me out I guess that that
would be putting the job back on you
guys
let's see super chat Dave your thoughts
on the recent Munk debate between Jordan
B Peterson and Michael Eric Dyson keep
up the good work and call Shapiro when
you need a lifeline fighter pensive I've
got Shapiro on speed-dial don't worry so
I didn't see the debate yet I've heard a
tremendous amount about it obviously
I've been traveling and I was with
Jordan so I just haven't had time Jordan
did talk about it a little bit but I
don't want to
repeat any of that here because I just
don't want to even slightly misquote him
or anything but it sounds like it was
him and Stephen Fry first Michael Eric
Dyson and I think her name's Michelle
Goldberg
on free speech and political correctness
I suspect I'm going to agree more with
Stephen Fry and and Jordan but I will I
will check it out all right let's see
I'm interested in getting in on the
conversation in the public light any
advice on where to start yeah get on
YouTube man get on YouTube just start
saying what you think start saying what
you think that's what all of you guys
are doing the more of these videos you
share forget about what I'm doing for a
second the more that you just in your
own life say what you think that's all
that I'm doing get out there and do it
we need you out there the more they will
realize that they can't destroy us all
with the mob that we're gonna stand up
for ourselves we're not gonna live in
fear and cowardice and that we're not
bad people and that we're not bigots and
racists and the rest of the things that
they say about us and that we want all
people black people and Muslim people
and trans people and everything else to
live equally as I repeatedly said at the
University of New Hampshire event
although the the protesters weren't that
happy you know that was a good example
of what's going on here actually you
know the protesters that came there they
don't listen like I I could see who they
were from the beginning right you can
figure it out because they had
noisemakers and they're kind of looking
at me dismissively and some some with
just out out trade hatred which is
really disturbing when you see like a
couple young people I go I suppose of
any age just staring at you with true
hatred like and I could see it in them
really I could
you're not gonna affect those people
that much you can they have to break out
of that themselves at some point but all
of the other people that were there to
be to listen respectfully and hear about
ideas and engage in the conversations
that's what it's all about and those are
the people that you can get and I think
in a weird way the more that these
people become hysterical the more
they're pushing people to us so again
this is why whatever this group of
people is the reason we all keep getting
pushed together and the reason that a
guy on the left like Sam Harris could be
pushed this way and a guy like Ben
Shapiro could be pushed this way is that
what I think is in the middle is it's
not
politics about freedom so when you take
these two guys I mean this to me is the
best example they disagree on literally
everything from God and existential
issues to taxes and abortion and
everything else but they're allies
because they're both fighting for their
right to be able to think freely and
express themselves freely and that is a
beautiful thing and that's what it's all
about
okay real quick here oh all right a lot
of people still asking about the
sweatshirt Ruben report comstor we got
we got sweatshirts t-shirts cutoff so
all kinds of stuff and while do I'll do
the pimp out one more time
June 3rd Tempe Arizona at the Tempe
improv June 7th at the DC improv and
Seattle on June 20th at the parlor live
if you are watching this and you're one
of the first 20 people to buy tickets to
any of those events and the links are
right down below we will upgrade you for
free to get into the meet and greet with
me after and we can hang out and say hi
and all that good stuff all you got to
do is buy the ticket and then just
screenshot it send it to contact at
Reuben report calm my guys were on it
and we'll take good care yeah what are
your predictions for the midterm
elections so look I said a couple months
maybe two months ago that I didn't think
it was gonna be this you know they
talked about the blue wave and the
Democratic wave and all that I just
don't really see it now it's a you have
to remember with midterms it's
particularly hard to judge these things
properly because so few people vote that
it's only about voter turnout so it's a
little hard harder to gauge I think than
a presidential election what I would say
is that I see a lot of reason to think
that there won't be a blue wave if
anything there will be a red wave I
think it partly has to do with Kanye
West and Canada's Owens where I think
the black community is starting to break
I mean a poll came out right after the
Kanye West thing that said black mail
support for Trump doubled from 11 to 22
percent within a week if that had been
any other president in the history of
the world people would have gone bananas
mainstream basically ignored that black
mail support for the president doubled
in a week and barely anybody talked
about that so I still think you know I
see people all the time people come up
to me here in LA where you can't really
say you're a trump supporter or
Republican or what
and they know that I'm not I don't even
vote for the guy and they'll come up to
me and saying you know Dave I I'm so
sick of this political correctness stuff
I mean the same stuff that was happening
before the election that has just ramped
up even more that they're subtly they're
like I kind of I'm carnist starting to
like crumb it's weird it's really weird
so I don't know that there's gonna be a
blue wave again it's all about turnout
it what I think will happen is that
within the we'll do some shows obviously
you're leading up to it and I would say
that about two weeks before the election
that's when we'll really be able to
figure out what's going on here sort of
around the 20th or so of October because
that's when we'll see really like which
base is more enthused and which is in
and just what is I mean there's so many
X factors it's hard to figure it out
this this early on so all these people
that pretend they know what they're
saying I mean they just don't okay let's
see what single book has had the
greatest impact on changing your way of
thinking or worldview well you know I've
been traveling with with on liberty by
John Stuart Mill and it's a very easy
read and I would recommend that all of
you guys get it but I think you know
there's so many great books here from so
many great people but one book that I do
reference a lot and and I think it was
formative for me for several reasons so
I'm in 1997 I was a I think I was a
junior I was either a sophomore or
junior in college and I saw the movie
contact the movie with Jodie Foster and
Matthew McConaughey it's the only book
of fiction ever written by Carl Sagan
and I just thought it was the most
wonderful movie about all of the things
that I care about the battle between
science and religion and and government
and belief and all of these things by
the way I just watched it a few months
ago now it's even more relevant in a
weird way than ever before and it's done
by Robert Zemeckis who's brilliant who
did Apollo 13 and far as confident
budget writers though anyway that movie
got me to read the book contact which is
also wonderful but then it got me to
read many other Carl Sagan books and his
last book which a lot of people don't
even know about and he actually passed
away before he finished it and then his
wife Ann Druyan who's also a professor
at Cornell she actually finished the
book or at least did the last paragraph
it's called billions and billions and
it's funny because Carl opens the book
by
saying that you know for some of you
guys that are a little older you remain
remember Johnny Carson doing an
impression of of Carl Sagan saying
billions and billions talking about
stars apparently Carl Sagan actually
never even said that phrase but people
used to attributed to him all the time
but that's why he titled it billions and
billions and it's just a wonderful book
on tribalism and religion and he talks a
little bit about about I think he talks
a little bit about marijuana or maybe
that's in cosmos it's just it's just a
wonderful book that's he's his true gift
was being able to communicate science
and thoughtful ideas to sort of regular
people so if you're looking for just
something readable that's not like
hundreds of pages that's gonna like slam
you with complex information but
something that can open up some of the
doors for this stuff billions and
billions by Carl Sagan I can't I can't
recommend it any higher all right okay
we got it we got to wrap this thing up
cuz I got two guests coming I just came
in from Philly this morning I got two
guests coming which you'll find out
about in the next couple of days so just
a reminder guys June 7th attempt a
improv June I'm sorry June 7th yeah no
June 3rd at Tempe improv June 7th at the
DCM prod and June 20th at Seattle parlor
live the links are right down below and
if you do buy this and you're one of the
first people to buy tickets while you're
watching this one of the first 20 at any
of those locations you're getting in for
the meet-and-greet for absolutely free
just screen shy or ticket contact at
Reuben Airport calm anyway all right I'm
gonna take a few minutes to throw a
little water on my face collect myself
we got we got two shows coming up today
and and then I'm home actually for the
weekend where I'm gonna try to relax a
little bit and just chill out and not
spend time online or any of that other
stuff and and then we're back out on the
road I on Tuesday we're in Houston and
then I think the next night we're in
Dallas and then Austin and we're just
rolling on so we're doing this basically
the rest of May the rest of June we're
doing a ton of it in July I signed on
for most of those and then Jordan is
actually going to continue into August
but I'm doing the off-the-grid for
August thing so I had to say no to the
to the rest of that and I want to talk
more about my ideas for for me going off
the grid and I want to challenge some
you guys perhaps to join me on this many
of you know I did this last year we're
locked my phone in a safe and didn't
watch the news didn't do anything online
no computers no no television or
anything nothing electronic and it was
true was life-changing and I'm gonna do
it again in August and I think this year
I'm gonna I'm gonna challenge you guys
to maybe try a version of it for
yourself if not for the month maybe for
a week or whatever you can do anyway I'm
super psyched about what's going on make
sure you're subscribed to the channel of
course make sure you're getting the the
notifications with that little bell but
who the hell knows what's going on and
lots of cool stuff happening and that is
all over and out